.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Vielleicht rettet Ihnen einer
dieser jungen Menschen mal das Leben.
Sie sind
angehende Pflegefachkräfte ...
... oder Rettungssanitäterin.
Die Ausbildung ist streng, der Beruf
spannend, aber anspruchsvoll.
Rebecca, Fanny ...
... Hélène und Lucas
wollen in einer Branche arbeiten,
die viele andere verlassen.
Warum - das erzählt diese Serie.
Yverdon, Samstagmorgen.
Uff, ist das heiss.
Und jetzt noch die Sonnenbrille.
Fanny schliesst ihre dreijährige Aus-
bildung als Rettungssanitäterin ab.
Sie geht teilweise noch zur Schule.
Die restliche Zeit arbeitet sie
beim Rettungs- und Notfallzentrum
Waadtland-Broye.
Du solltest noch
eine Durchsage machen.- Stimmt.
Begleitet wird sie von der routi-
nierten Rettungssanitäterin Amélie.
144, Nova 31, antworten.
Für ihre erste Fahrt heute wurden sie
wegen eines anscheinend
kleinen Unfalls aufgeboten.
Ist gut. Danke.
Man sagte uns, jemand sei bewusstlos
und habe sich
an der rechten Hand verletzt.
Das kommt gut.
Das haben wir bald.
Picobello, whoop, whoop, whoop.
Wir dachten, es sei etwas Kleines.
Das würde schnell gehen.
Manchmal wird die Ambulanz wegen
kleinster Verletzungen aufgeboten.
Hinfahren muss man aber trotzdem.
Grüezi.
Erzählen Sie mir, was passiert ist.
Ich sass dort am Pool
und liess die Hände hängen.
Dann fällt plötzlich
der Sonnenschirm um.
Ja, es hatte Wind und ...
- ... er fiel auf Ihre Hand.
Darf ich es mir genauer anschauen?
Meine Finger sind ganz zerquetscht.
Ein Windstoss hat den Sonnenschirm
auf die Hand
der 87-jährigen Raymonde umgekippt.
Ich schaue nicht.
- Nein, Raymonde, nicht schauen.
Spüren Sie meine Hand?
- Ja.
Wir haben kontrolliert, ob sie
alle Finger spüren und bewegen kann.
Das machen wir, um zu wissen,
ob die Nerven beschädigt sind.
Das ist komplett durchgetrennt.
- Ja.
Au, das spüre ich.
- Tut mir leid.
Was denkst du?
- Wir müssen sie mitnehmen.
Je schneller wir reagieren,
desto grösser ist die Chance,
die Finger zu retten
und sie zusammenzubringen,
wenn sie noch da sind.
Los, wir gehen. Haben Sie Schuhe?
Die Situation ist kritisch, weil
der Finger ganz abgetrennt wurde.
Wir wissen nicht,
ob sie sofort angerufen haben
oder ob viel Zeit verloren ging.
Da ist der Fall klar:
einfach vorwärtsmachen.
Raymonde muss so schnell wie möglich
in ein Spital
mit Spezialisten für Handchirurgie.
Wann ist das passiert?
- (Frau) Vor ca. 20 Min.
Okay.
Die Patientin geht zum Auto.
Das geht schneller
als mit einer Tragbahre.
Müssen Sie sich übergeben?
- Ja, ich glaube.
Okay. Hast du ein Brechsäckchen?
- Ja.
* Würgen *
Hat sie Allergien?
Nein.
- Auf Medikamente ...
Ähm ...
Ich weiss es leider nicht.
Entschuldigen Sie die Frage,
aber haben Sie
die Fingerkuppe irgendwo gesehen?
Es fehlte
einfach noch ein Teil des Fingers.
Der lag möglicherweise
noch unter dem Sonnenschirm.
Im Spital braucht es
beide Fingerteile. Das ist wichtig.
Hat sie viel Blut verloren?
- Nein, nicht viel.
Es blutete nur ein bisschen.
- Alles klar. Okay.
Man muss die Wunde
unbedingt mit Eis kühlen,
damit man überhaupt eine Chance hat,
den Finger zu retten.
Machst du ein Foto vorher?
- Ja.- Ich mache gleich eins.
Mit dem Foto
kann der Arzt beurteilen,
wie schlimm die Verletzung ist,
ohne den Verband abnehmen zu müssen.
Da kommt der Knochen raus.
Wir gehen nach Fribourg.
Dort sagen sie uns, ob sie ihn
nähen können oder abnehmen müssen.
Sie haben alles richtig gemacht:
Schatten, Wunde gekühlt ...
Das war wichtig. Sehr gut.
- Dank ihm.
Er hat mal im Spital gearbeitet.
- Wirklich gut gemacht.
Es war mir wichtig, sie zu loben,
weil das, was sie tun,
häufig richtig ist.
Alles Gute.
- (Raymonde) Ade. Ade.
Lob tut gut. Dann fühlen sie sich
auch weniger schuldig.
* Sirene *
Ich weiss,
es schaukelt ein bisschen.
Sagen Sie, wenn Ihnen übel wird.
Im Moment geht es gerade.
- Sehr gut.
Je nach Route
kann es ziemlich schaukeln.
Die Sachen rutschen rum ...
V.a. auf kleinen Strassen
oder in Kurven.
Wir sollten eine konstante
Geschwindigkeit beibehalten.
Aber wir dürfen nicht vergessen,
dass hinten jemand ist.
Aber wir müssen vorwärtskommen.
Die Leute auf der Strasse
wissen manchmal nicht,
wie sie reagieren sollen.
Dann sind sie uns nur im Weg,
und alles verzögert sich.
Fahr mal. Entschuldigung.
Hinten im Auto versucht Amélie,
Raymonde etwas zu beruhigen.
Fahren Sie noch Auto?
- Nein, ich habe aufgehört.
Ich finde es gut, während der Fahrt
mit den Patienten zu sprechen.
Es tut ihnen gut und lenkt sie ab.
Im Spital geht es ihnen dann besser,
und es kommt sogar vor,
dass sie lächeln.
So, wie geht es Ihnen?
- Es geht.
Gut kann ich nicht sagen.
- Ja klar, das kann ich verstehen.
Salut.
- Guten Tag.- (Mann) Hallo.
Oh, das hält nicht richtig.
Gar nicht.
Hältst du die Hand bitte so?
Der Verband ist total locker.
Tut mir leid.
- Alles im Griff.
Auf drei: eins, zwei, drei.
Prima.
So sieht das aus.
- Da kommt der Knochen raus.
Kann man das zusammennähen?
Und all das wegen einer Sonnenblume.
Einer Sonnenblume?
- Quatsch, eines Sonnenschirms.
(Mann)
Wegen einer riesigen Sonnenblume.
Und was für eine.
- So.
Grüezi, mein Name ist Maxime,
ich bin Ihr Arzt.
(Raymonde) Grüezi.
- Grüezi.
Ich bin keine Chirurgin
und weiss nicht, was möglich ist.
Es hat ihr
einen Teil des Fingers abgerissen.
Es war nur ein kleiner Teil,
aber ... Ich weiss nicht.
Wunder können passieren.
Mal schauen.
Frau Pilloud, wir verabschieden uns.
- Machen Sie es gut.
Gute Besserung.
- Sie waren so nett zu mir.
Vielen Dank.
- Sehr gerne.- Ade.
Fanny und Amélie
haben ihre Aufgabe erfüllt.
Der Einsatz
verlief anders als gedacht.
Damit habe ich nicht gerechnet.
- Ich auch nicht.
Wir haben noch darüber gespöttelt.
- Fast gelästert.
Das haben wir aber gut gemacht.
Sehr gut sogar.
Es war sehr gut.
Es war eine gute Erfahrung.
Das nächste Mal halten wir uns
zurück mit Kommentaren.
* Entspannte Musik *
Wir sind mit Hélène
in der Lausanner Klinik La Source.
Mit 1'000 Studierenden
ist das die grösste Hochschule
für Pflegefachkräfte in der Schweiz.
Die Ausbildung dauert drei Jahre.
Dann hat man einen Bachelor.
Heute gilt es, möglichst schnell
einen venösen Zugang zu legen.
Es ist zwar nur ein Plastikarm,
aber man hat auch nur 3 Min. Zeit,
weil der fiktive Patient dann
dringend wiederbelebt werden muss.
Das Prozedere ist Ihnen bekannt.
Sie müssen schnell sein,
und natürlich präzise.
Am Arm
kann man nicht viel falsch machen,
aber wir schauen genau zu.
Sie haben also enormen Druck.
Und Sie sollten
in 3 Min. fertig sein.
Pro Arm nur eine Person.
- (Frau) Pascal, Stoppuhr?
(Pascal) Bereit? Los.
* Spannende Musik *
(Frau) Hopp, hopp.
Los, vorwärts.
Hast du alles?
Hélène hat das Wichtigste vergessen:
die Spritze.
Ich war im Stress.
3 Min. Zeit,
und alles musste stimmen.
Ich kannte das Material nicht
und wusste nicht, wo was war.
Logo, die Spritze.
Das hätte ich sicher gemerkt.
Okay, sehr gut.
Schneller. 40 Sek. sind vorbei.
- Ja. Ich mache schnell.
Er braucht dringend Adrenalin.
Ich darf keine Fehler machen,
die Ausbildner schauen zu ...
"Was denken sie? Mache ich es gut?"
Das fragt man sich ständig.
Weiter.
Dem Patienten geht es schlecht.
Er braucht Morphin
und dafür den Zugang. Schnell, hopp.
Das Ausbildungsteam setzt die
Studierenden immer mehr unter Druck.
Man weiss, man muss schnell sein.
Wird einem das auch noch gesagt,
gibt es noch mehr Stress und man
kann sich nicht mehr konzentrieren.
Wir haben einen Notfall.
Es sollte schneller gehen.
Im täglichen Einsatz
ist das genau gleich.
Alle sprechen mit einem
und man sollte noch mehr machen,
obwohl man noch nicht fertig ist.
Ziehen, ziehen, ziehen,
ziehen, ziehen, ziehen, ziehen.
Voilà.
- Eine gute Idee.- 1 Min. 15 Sek.
Hélène musste als Praktikantin
immer wieder Venenkatheter legen.
Aber noch nie
in einer solchen Notfallsituation.
Vorwärts machen.
- Noch 1 Min.
Der Zeitdruck
macht alles noch schwieriger:
Die Lernenden machen mehr Fehler
und vergessen
gewisse Vorsichtsmassnahmen.
Hast du desinfiziert?
Es ist wichtig,
vorher zu desinfizieren.
Ich komme mir dumm vor, das
nicht automatisch gemacht zu haben.
Es sollte ein Reflex sein.
Aber im Stress vergass ich es.
Komm.
Jetzt muss man
nur noch den Schlauch anschliessen.
Hélène ist nicht schnell genug.
Es blutet. Vorsichtig mit der Vene.
- Es fliesst stark.
Es blutet.
- Die Übung endet in einem Blutbad.
Alles ist voller Blut.
Das Bett, der Patient ...
Achtung,
zieh den Venenstauer fester an.
Das passiert am Anfang oft.
(Frau) Es lief gut. Nur das
mit dem Venenstau war nicht klar.
Fertig?
- Ja.- 5 Min. 39 Sek.
5 Min. 39 Sek. brauchte Hélène -
viel länger als 3 Min.
Sonst fliesst das ganze Blut
einfach raus.
Klar.
Es braucht einfach
Übung, Übung und noch mal Übung.
Wir machen das auf der Notaufnahme,
in der Kardiologie etc. so oft,
bis man es intus hat.
Nicht alle Patienten
haben gleich gute Venen.
Einige haben sehr schlechte.
Dann wird es kompliziert.
Das hängt auch von der Tagesform ab.
Manchmal klappt es
und manchmal will es einfach nicht.
Reinstechen und dann geht es.
- Okay. Alles klar.
In meinem letzten Praktikum
hat eine Anästhesistin
einen Zugang in 1 Min. gelegt.
Sie hatte nur 1 Min.
Das ist beeindruckend.
Ein richtiges Vorbild.
Es braucht Zeit, das zu lernen,
aber irgendwann kann ich das auch.
Ich zittere ein bisschen.
Unter Zeitdruck
weiss der Kopf manchmal nichts mehr.
Es ist zwar klar, dass man
keine Sekunde verlieren darf,
aber plötzlich
ist man durcheinander.
Man weiss nicht mehr wie, wo, was
und handelt unlogisch.
Puh. Ui, ui.
Ui, ui, ui, ui, ui.
- Wo sind die Männer?
Es hat doch keine.
- Es hat keine Männer.
Dort ist die Kamera.
Bald haben alle hier
ihr Praktikum abgeschlossen
und werden in einem Spital
ins Berufsleben einsteigen.
Perfekt.
Nicht mehr Studentin zu sein,
ist sicher besonders.
Dann kommt sicher Nostalgie auf,
wenn ich daran zurückdenke.
Aber das Berufsleben
ist auch für gestandene Pflege-
fachleute interessant und spannend.
Wir sind
im Spital Trois-Chêne in Genf.
(Yamina)
Lass dich nicht unter Druck setzen.
(Lucas) Okay.
Lucas macht gerade mit Yamina,
seiner Chefin, Pause.
Willst du einen Kaffee?
Oder einen Tee?
Nein, danke,
lieber einen Fruchtsaft.
So.
Findest du nicht auch, es sei heiss?
- Das ist der Stress.
Deine dritte Woche hier.
Die dritte Praktikumswoche
im geriatrischen Notfalldienst.
Zeit, dass Lucas sich alleine
um einen Patienten kümmert.
Machen wir
die Patientenaufnahme zusammen?
Das Ziel ist,
dass du total selbstständig wirst.
Finde ich gut.
- Ist gut. Du schaffst das.
Lucas geht zum Empfang und übernimmt
die nächste Notaufnahme.
Hey, hey.
- Ich rufe dich, wenn er kommt.
Nein.
Wir machen es
wie im Film "Die Stadtflitzer".
Okay.
Auf keinen Fall rufen bei Problemen.
Auf dem Notfallparkplatz
kommt und geht
ein Krankenwagen nach dem anderen.
Jean-Charles ist einseitig gelähmt.
Seine Frau, die sich sonst
um ihn kümmert, ist auch im Spital.
Darum war der 83-Jährige
auf einer temporären Station.
Dort kriegte er
plötzlich hohes Fieber.
Die Fieberschwelle liegt bei älteren
Leuten normalerweise tiefer.
Man spricht also schon
bei 37,6 °C oder 37,8 °C von Fieber.
Wenn jemand 39 °C hat,
ist das beunruhigend.
Das ist hohes Fieber.
Und je älter jemand ist,
desto weniger hält er
hohe Körpertemperaturen aus.
Eins, zwei, drei.
So, der Herr. Sie sind im Bett.
Wir machen es noch bequemer. Moment.
So, zu mir rüber.
- Au.- Achtung, das Knie.
* Abwartende Musik *
Jetzt muss man ein Zimmer finden.
Aber alle Betten auf der Abteilung
sind besetzt.
Grüezi.
Wir bringen den Herrn in die 7.
Die Patientin kann drinbleiben.
- Nein. Zu kompliziert.
Also, gehen wir.
Alles gut soweit?
- Was machen wir?
Ein paar Dinge.
Wir nehmen sicher mal Blut.
Dann müssen wir ...
- Das haben Sie schon zweimal.
Nur schon heute.
Heute schon zweimal?
Aber bevor Sie hierherkamen.
Ja, schauen Sie, was ich hier habe.
Ja, ich sehe es.
Das ist aber nicht von hier.
Man kann Ihnen
anscheinend nichts vormachen.
Nein, dieses Mal nicht.
Also.
Wollen Sie mich quälen?
Um Gottes Willen, nein.
Sicher nicht.
Ich quäle Leute nicht gerne.
Ich will Ihnen nicht wehtun.
Lucas ist genauso gestresst
wie der Patient.
Jetzt ziehe ich an. Okay?
- Ja.
Einen Venenkatheter zu legen
ist für alle Studierenden
eine Herausforderung,
v.a. bei einem älteren Patienten.
Ältere Menschen
haben manchmal Rollvenen
oder sehr zarte oder schwache Adern.
Darum sagt man häufig:
Wer in der Geriatrie stechen kann,
kann das bei allen Patienten.
Machen Sie bitte eine Faust.
Super. Hoppla. Ich lasse Sie ...
Ganz fest zusammendrücken, bitte.
Sehr gut.
Einfach nichts. Ich sehe keine Vene.
Ich spüre auch keine.
Wirklich nichts.
Nichts, wo ich stechen könnte,
um den Katheter zu legen.
Ich spüre keine. Bis auf diese hier.
Und auch die ist nur schwach.
Siehst du was?
Das ist die einzige.
- Lös mal den Venenstau.
Lucas braucht Hilfe von Nathalie.
Sie ist
eine erfahrene Pflegefachfrau.
* Erwartungsvolle Musik *
Sie ist sehr kurz.
- Traust du dir das zu?
Ich spürte sie. Ganz kurz.
Aber nur ein wenig.
Ich möchte nichts falsch machen,
wenn die Stelle so klein ist.
Sonst sind wir aufgeschmissen.
Sonst machen wir
eine Dopplersonografie.
Mit einem Arzt
geht das gut und gerne 45 Min.
Machen Sie bitte eine Faust.
Lucas lässt Nathalie machen.
So, wir sind fertig.
Es ist frustrierend.
Man ist kein guter Pfleger, nur weil
man gute menschliche Qualitäten hat.
Es braucht mehr. Man muss
die Technik auch beherrschen.
Wunderbar.
In einem halben Jahr
wird Lucas in einem Spital arbeiten
und auf sich alleine gestellt sein.
Ich suche mal Ihr Handy.
Ist es das?
- Ja, genau.
Voilà.
Bitte.
Jetzt kann Jean-Charles
seine Frau informieren,
die in einem anderen Spital ist.
Sie musste
den grauen Star operieren.
Sorgen mache ich mir keine. Sie
ist mind. so stark wie ein Pferd.
Sie ist eine Preussin.
Wenn ich Sie so anschaue,
könnten Sie aus dem Balkan sein.
Stimmt das?
- Gar nicht. Ich bin hier geboren.
Meine Jungs sind auch hier geboren.
Den Kopf haben sie von sonst wo.
V.a. ältere Personen sind neugierig.
Sie wollen wissen,
woher jemand kommt.
Sie sprechen auch gerne darüber.
Das finde ich lustig.
Mein Vater kommt aus Genf
und meine Mutter ist Walliserin.
Oh, also stur und stur.
- Das kann man sagen.
Der Vater muss folgen.
Aus zwei sturen Köpfen
gibt es einen dritten.
Für mich gehört zur Pflege dazu,
dass ich die Leute kennenlerne.
Das ist mir wichtig.
Ich pflege nicht gerne,
ohne zu plaudern.
Das reicht nicht, finde ich.
Ich diskutiere gerne und manchmal
lacht man auch zusammen.
Das ist hilfreich und tut gut.
Wie geht es Ihnen?
Haben Sie Schmerzen? Z.B. im Knie?
Ich möchte in Ruhe gelassen werden.
- Dann lassen wir Sie.
Ich komme später noch mal vorbei.
Bis dann.- Ja.
Lucas muss jetzt noch alles,
was er heute gemacht hat,
genau aufschreiben.
Eine undankbare Arbeit, die von den
Patienten nicht wahrgenommen wird.
Pfleger sitzen viel am Computer.
Man muss gezwungenermassen
genau Buch führen.
Über alles, was man gemacht hat,
und wie man es gemacht hat.
Man muss alles zurückverfolgen
können, falls es ein Problem gibt.
Sonst wird es sehr kompliziert.
Während Lucas
seinen Papierkram erledigt ...
... ist Fanny mit ihrer Kollegin
wieder in Yverdon unterwegs.
Die Polizei
hat die Ambulanz aufgeboten,
um einen stark alkoholisierten Mann
zu transportieren.
Man sagte uns,
dass da jemand total betrunken sei.
Und dass die Polizei vor Ort sei.
Mehr Information gab es nicht.
Er ist sicher Typ "heulendes Elend",
weil er
eine Trennung hinter sich hat.
Und weil er so einsam ist,
gab er sich völlig die Kante
und hat noch Medikamente geschluckt.
Wir müssen ihm klarmachen,
dass wir ihn kurz kontrollieren,
um zu schauen,
ob alles in Ordnung ist.
Und er solle vielleicht psycho-
logische Hilfe in Anspruch nehmen.
Dann gehen wir wieder
und wünschen ...
Fanny kann sich
alles Mögliche vorstellen.
Tatsache ist: Die beiden Sanitä-
terinnen haben keine Informationen.
Sie wissen nicht, was passiert ist.
- Grüezi.
Grüezi. Ich heisse Fanny.
Bleiben Sie sitzen.
Erzählen Sie uns, was los ist.
(Mann, aufgeregt)
Ich bin nicht gemein.
Das sind Sie sicher nicht.
Das glaube ich.
Wir müssen Sie
in den Notfall mitnehmen.
Sie haben
ziemlich viel Alkohol getrunken.
(Lallend) Denken Sie?
Sie tranken Alkohol
und sind nicht so fit.
Aber nicht so ...
- Einverstanden?
Die Polizei schlägt vor,
die Sanitäterinnen zu begleiten.
Nein, das geht schon. Das ist nett.
Kommen Sie mit uns mit?
Das wäre gut.- Klar.
Sehr gut. Also, kommen Sie.
Er machte einen stabilen Eindruck
und kooperierte.
Darum wäre es zu viel gewesen,
die Polizei dabeizuhaben.
Wir waren
auch in der Nähe des Spitals.
Darum hätte es
eigentlich klappen sollen.
(Mann) Haben Sie alles?
- Ja, ja.
* Erwartungsvolle Musik *
Hinter Ihnen. Da.
Kommen Sie hierher.
- Die Polizei.
Das ist ja gut.
Ich bin nicht gemein.
- (Amélie) Ich weiss.
Das ist wie im Auto.
Man muss sich angurten.
Das müssen alle. Sogar wir.
Gewalt macht mir am meisten Angst.
Alle alkoholisierten Leute,
die Medikamente genommen haben,
können gewalttätig werden.
Manchmal unterschätzt man
die unheimliche Kraft,
die sie entwickeln können.
Man muss immer einen Fluchtweg
offen haben und mit allem rechnen.
Wir schreien, wenn es nötig ist.
- Ist gut.
Merci.
* Piepstöne *
(Weinerlich) Tut mir leid.
* Er weint. *
Grausam.
Ich möchte mich
bei Ihnen entschuldigen.
Das haben Sie vorher schon.
Ich habe total versagt.
Fahr nur. Gib Gas.
- Ich habe schon gedreht.
Fanny will möglichst schnell
ins Spital.
Sie hat
die Polizeibegleitung abgelehnt
und ist jetzt alleine
hinten mit dem Patienten.
Und der ist unberechenbar.
- Das ist nicht lustig.
Das verstehe ich gut.
Das ist keine einfache Situation.
Aber nicht wegen Ihnen.
- Ich weiss. Es geht nicht um mich.
Nein. Sie sind nett.
- Ich weiss. Gerne geschehen.
Er weinte, kooperierte aber.
Trotzdem kann es von einem Moment
auf den anderen umschlagen.
Es braucht nicht viel,
bis jemand komplett ausflippt.
Man weiss es nie.
Tschau, hier ist Fanny,
Nova 31 mit C2-Intox.
Im Moment kooperativ.
Fanny informiert das Spital.
Aber sie will den Patienten
nicht provozieren
und spricht daher
nicht von Alkoholvergiftung,
sondern braucht
die medizinische Abkürzung.
Amélie ist klar, dass die Situation
jeden Moment eskalieren kann.
Aber sie kann nicht viel machen.
Das kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen.
- Kann man das ausmachen?
Ich merkte,
dass er sich immer mehr aufregte.
Dann muss man beruhigen
und gut zureden.
Am besten nicht zeigen,
dass man Angst hat.
Und hoffen,
dass sich die Situation beruhigt.
Ich verstehe,
dass es nicht einfach ist.
Nein, das ist es wirklich nicht.
Das dürfen Sie so sagen.
Das Psychologische und die Empathie
sind entscheidend.
Nach einer achtminütigen Fahrt
mit mulmigem Gefühl
kommt die Ambulanz
endlich im Notfall an.
Fanny konnte Ruhe bewahren.
(Wütend) Endlich raus.
- Ja.
So, das können wir wegnehmen.
Achtung, aufpassen.
Die Tritte sind hoch.
Verstanden.
Sehr gut.
- Geht es?
Wir müssen dort nach hinten.
- Kommen Sie. Hier durch.
Alles klar. Kommen Sie mit uns.
Kommen Sie.
- Ah. Sind wir schon da?
Als die beiden Rettungssanitäterinnen
wieder abfahren,
sind sie noch ziemlich angespannt.
Da haben wir wieder was erlebt.
- Völlig abgefahren.
Wir hatten null Information
von der Polizei.
Ich verstand ihn auch nicht immer.
Als die Polizei mitfahren wollte,
dachte ich, es gehe.
Ich weiss, was du meinst.
Dachte ich anfangs auch.
Aber dann ... Ja.
Er war einer, der auf einmal
total aggressiv hätte werden können.
Absolut.
Da hinten dachte ich ...
Das hätte anders rauskommen können.
Wir hätten die Polizei
mitnehmen sollen.- Ja.
Wie meine Kollegin sagte: Die
Polizisten waren schon länger dort.
Darum haben sie uns angeboten,
mitzukommen.
Das hätten wir annehmen sollen.
Im Universitätsspital Genf
treffen wir Rebecca wieder.
Sie ist im dritten Ausbildungsjahr
und macht ein Praktikum in
der Abteilung für Viszeralchirurgie.
Guten Morgen, Capitaine Gigi.
Wie geht es?
Er sagte mir am ersten Tag ...
... er habe einen Wunsch.
Und ich: "Okay."
"Sprechen Sie mich
mit 'Capitaine Gigi' an."
Bestens, Capitaine Gigi.
Ist in der Akte vermerkt.
Sie haben nachher
eine Computertomografie.
Um zu sehen, wie es geht.
- Wo?
Unten. Jemand wird Sie dann holen.
Jetzt dann gleich.
René war Sicherheitsbeamter,
Feuerwehrmann
und leidenschaftlicher Bootsfahrer.
Frühstück gibt es erst nach dem CT,
Herr Girardin.
Ja, meinetwegen.
Jetzt muss ich die Mitteilung lesen.
Man musste den 80-Jährigen
wegen eines Tumors operieren.
Ich habe noch ein CT.
(Frau) Wirklich? Am Morgen?
- Ja.
Gut. Ich komme am Nachmittag.
- Ja, das ist gut.
Bis dann. Tschüss.
- Gut. Bis heute Nachmittag.
Bis später, mein Held.
Süss.
Wenn ich feste Nahrung ass,
konnte es hier blockieren.
Wäre ich nicht rechtzeitig gekommen,
wäre ich jetzt da oben.
Oder im Keller. Im Höllenfeuer.
Es war alles auf der Kippe.
Und hier blühen Sie auf?
- Ja. Alles bestens.
All right, very good.
- All right, very good.
Die Operation verlief gut,
aber René hat einen künstlichen
Darmausgang mit einem Beutel,
um den er sich selber kümmern sollte.
Verstehen Sie, wie es funktioniert?
Es ist mir lieber,
wenn Madame dabei ist und zuschaut.
Es ist ...
- Ihre Frau?
Ich kann das nicht.
- Haben Sie es versucht?
Nein, das kann ich nicht.
Versuchen Sie es.
- Ich kann mich nicht bewegen.
Es ist mir lieber,
wenn sie das macht.
Er sagte sofort,
seine Frau solle sich darum kümmern.
Er will es nicht machen.
Ich glaube, er hat Mühe damit,
seine Ileostomie ...
... den künstlichen Darmausgang
richtig anzunehmen.
Ja. Ich muss damit leben.
Es hat keinen Sinn,
deswegen durchzudrehen.
Darf ich?
- Ja.
Das wird lustig.
Sie haben doch das Sagen.
Trotzdem.
Wir sehen uns später. Tschüss.
- Klar.
"Tschüss" klingt für Chefin Lore
etwas zu salopp.
Rebecca, das ist zu kollegial.
Aha.
- Du solltest nicht "Tschüss" sagen.
Sag "Bis später".
- Ja.
Das sind nicht deine Freunde.
- Du hast recht.
In der Runde wird besprochen,
ob man René nicht besser auf
eine andere Abteilung bringen sollte,
bis er sich
an den Beutel gewöhnt hat.
Seine Frau war nicht begeistert.
Sie hat nicht zugestimmt,
sich darum zu kümmern.
Er habe das einfach gesagt.
Sie haben nicht darüber gesprochen.
Pflegefachfrauen
müssen einfühlsam vorgehen,
damit der Patient nach Hause kann.
Wie sich das wohl
aufs Heimgehen auswirkt?
Das müssen wir klären.
In Genf muss Lucas seine Patienten
für die Nacht vorbereiten.
Er liegt ziemlich quer im Bett.
Ich habe Angst,
dass er rausfallen könnte.
Wir müssen die Barriere raufmachen.
- Die Hälfte.
Herr Stefani?
Sie haben noch zu hoch Fieber.
Ja?
- Ich möchte Ihnen Dafalgan geben.
Gut.
- Kennen Sie das?
Ja.
So, noch das.
Weil Jean-Charles linksseitig gelähmt
ist, muss Lucas darauf achten,
dass trotzdem
alles in seiner Reichweite ist.
Geht das so?
Kommen Sie an alles ran?
Mhm.
Wenn man halbseitig gelähmt ist,
muss man damit leben,
dass man nicht mehr
beide Hände brauchen kann.
Der Kunsthandwerker hat sein Leben
lang in seinem Atelier in Carouge
alte Bilderrahmen renoviert.
Ich bin Holzbildhauer von Beruf.
Ich war einer der letzten Mohikaner
der Republik.
Das mit der Fernbedienung des Bettes
ist etwas kompliziert.
Schauen Sie,
alles ist auf dieser Seite.
Es ist mit dem Bett verbunden.
Ich kann es nicht abnehmen.
Am besten so, dass ich es
mit dieser Hand bedienen kann.
Leider geht es nicht besser.
- Dann lassen wir es so.
Vielleicht
geht es mir irgendwann auch so.
Dann möchte ich auch,
dass man mich anständig behandelt.
Also, respektvoll und mit Mitgefühl.
Aber v.a., dass man sich
meinem Rhythmus anpasst.
Mit 80
ist man nicht mehr so in Form,
wie ich mit 23.
Die Pflegefachbetreuung
ist in drei Schichten aufgeteilt.
Jede dauert 8 Std.
Lucas Schicht
begann um 14 Uhr nachmittags
und dauert noch bis 22 Uhr abends.
Möchtest du dich etwas ausruhen?
Das wäre nicht schlecht.
Etwas essen.
Okay.
Das kann ich nachher noch machen.
- Ist gut.
Ist bei Ihnen alles gut?
- Ich liege etwas unbequem.
Das Kissen ist nicht gut.
So.
Jetzt sollte es besser sein.
- So ist es bequemer.
Wirklich?
- Ja.
Jean-Charles muss ein paar Tage
im Spital bleiben.
Er kann erst nach Hause,
wenn die Infektion geheilt ist.
Welche Unterlagen des Austritts
vorher muss ich behalten?
Das ist für die Ärzte.
- Okay.
Es ist 21 Uhr abends.
Das kommt ins Sekretariat.
Das nehme ich mit.- Alles klar.
Das können wir wieder brauchen.
Endlich kann Lucas etwas essen.
Ein langer Tag ist bald vorbei.
In der Abteilung für Viszeralchirur-
gie des Universitätsspitals Genf
beginnt um 22 Uhr die Nachtschicht.
Und das ist das Valium.
Und zwar 10 mg.
Rebecca muss alle Medikamente
für die Nacht vorbereiten
und wird dabei von ihrer Ausbildnerin
Emelie beaufsichtigt.
Pflegefachleute dürfen
erst im dritten Ausbildungsjahr
für die Nachtschicht
eingeteilt werden.
Rebecca hat etwas Angst
vor den drei Nachtschichten,
die vor ihr liegen.
Alle hintereinander -
es ist ein Marathon.
Ich mag es, wenn nachts etwas läuft.
So geht die Zeit schneller durch.
Wenn man am Computer sitzt
und Informationen raussucht,
fallen die Augen einfach so zu.
In der Nacht machen einem
v.a. die Müdigkeit und der Hunger
das Leben schwer.
Es ist so.
Das gehört zur Nachtschicht.
Aber ich habe immer Hunger.
Und während der Nachtschicht
noch viel mehr.
* Piepston *
Rebecca wird unterbrochen.
Die Alarmglocke läutet. Es ist René.
Gut.
Darf ich das Licht anmachen?
- Ja.- Gut.
Also, was ist los?
Da hinten.
Da stört etwas und es ist nass.
Die Ernährungssonde ist abgehängt.
Nicht?
- Doch.
Offensichtlich
hat sich etwas gelöst.
Schon wieder? Sie hat
doch Scotch-Kleber gebraucht.
Der Kleber ist weg.
Wissen Sie,
was Krankenpfleger falsch machen?
Das nimmt mich wunder.
- Sie kleben das Scotch an ...
... an den Körper.
Dabei gehört der doch ins Glas.
Ich trinke eben den Scotch.
- Ja, ja, ich weiss.
Es hat sich gelöst,
darum floss die Flüssigkeit raus.
Ich klebe es wieder ran.
- Ich bewege mich gar nicht.
Aber der Kleber wurde nass.
Darum hielt er nicht mehr.
Möchten Sie ein neues Nachthemd?
Das ist ganz feucht.
Das Leintuch auch.
- Das trocknet schnell.
Das ist doch unangenehm.
Was? Ich liege ja nicht drauf.
Machen wir es nicht kompliziert.
Nicht kompliziert.
Um die Zeit? Was denken Sie denn?
Er ist ein liebenswerter Mensch.
Er ist witzig, aufgestellt,
sympathisch und locker.
Einfach
ein total angenehmer Patient.
Erinnern Sie sich
an dieses Kinderlied?
# Tock, tock, wer ist da?
- # Das kleine Lotti.
# Was in deinem Höschen wohnt,
zeig uns deinen runden Mond.
Kennen Sie das? Nicht so vulgär.
- Das nicht.
Es ist ganz okay.
- Ja, ja.
So, dann schalte ich das Licht aus.
Könnten Sie mir
noch den Tisch hinstellen?
Mache ich. Gute Nacht.
In der Nacht sind die Pflegefachleute
auf sich alleine gestellt.
Ein Arzt oder eine Ärztin ist
im Notfall telefonisch erreichbar.
Sich hinzulegen und zu schlafen
ist nicht erlaubt.
Darum verbringt das Team
einen grossen Teil der Nacht
im Stationszimmer - dort ist es ruhig
und man kann sich austauschen.
Ich machte eine Lehre bei der Post
und schloss mit dem EFZ ab.
Ich arbeitete zwei Jahre Vollzeit
und fing dann die Weiterbildung an.
Am Samstag arbeite ich bei der Post.
- Warum Pflegefachfrau?
Es gefiel mir einfach nicht mehr.
Es lief irgendwie alles schief.
Ich wollte etwas machen,
das mir gefällt.
Ich bewarb mich
für eine Hebammenausbildung.
Ich bestand aber
die Aufnahmeprüfung nicht.
Für den Krankenpflegelehrgang
wurde ich angenommen.
Ich dachte, ich würde es nach
einem Jahr nochmals versuchen.
Aber ich liess es,
weil es mir hier so gut gefiel.
Ich bin stolz auf meinen Berufsweg.
Sicher. Klar.
Ich habe es trotz allem geschafft.
Mittlerweile
habe ich schon einiges erlebt.
Es freut mich, wenn man merkt,
dass ich eine gewisse Reife habe.
Ich spreche auch gerne darüber.
Man darf wissen,
was ich gemacht habe.
Und dass ich
aus dem Gesundheitsbereich komme.
Du arbeitest noch bei der Post?
Ja.
Und vorher arbeitete ich sonntags
bei der Migros am Flughafen.
Aber das war zu viel.
Mein Körper hat rebelliert.- Oh.
Zum Glück hast du aufgehört.
- Allerdings.
Es ist 4 Uhr morgens.
Rebecca
macht eine Runde durch die Zimmer.
Wir machen alle 2 Std. eine Runde.
Gewisse Patienten
brauchen auch in der Nacht
eine Tablette oder sonst Pflege.
Auch wenn sie schlafen,
müssen wir schauen, ob alles passt.
Ich schlafe tagsüber nicht gut.
Es ist ein anderer Schlaf
als in der Nacht.
Ich erhole mich nicht so gut.
Darum werde ich während
einer Nachtschicht immer müder.
In der ersten Nacht geht es noch,
aber schon in der zweiten
ist es manchmal mühsam.
Je nachdem,
wie empfindlich man reagiert,
geht das auf den Bauch,
und dann geht nichts mehr.
Der ganze Rhythmus
gerät völlig durcheinander.
So ist es.
Man möchte
eigentlich nur noch schlafen.
Es ist 5.30 Uhr morgens.
Gewisse Patienten
müssen schon geweckt werden.
Herr Girardin?
- Hm?
Aw. Morgen.
Ich muss Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
- Schon wieder?- Ja.
Oi, es werde Licht.
- Genau. So ist es.
Gott, oh Gott.
# De lundi au soleil, c'est quand
on est derrière les carreaux
# et que le ciel est beau.
Von wem ist das?
- Äh ...
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
- Das dachte ich mir.
Verraten Sie es uns?
Sie machen es ja spannend.
# Il pique, pique, pique,
pique, pique, rin-bam-bam.
So.
Schon fertig.
- Hm.
Die Blutkontrolle
macht man so früh am Morgen,
damit das Labor genug Zeit hat,
sie auszuwerten.
Um 9 Uhr ist Arztvisite.
Schichtwechsel -
im Stationszimmer geht es zu und her
wie in einem Bienenstock.
Rebecca übergibt alle Informationen
ihrer Patienten
an die Kolleginnen,
die jetzt übernehmen.
Er braucht immer noch das Urinal.
Wir sollten ihn
zum Aufstehen motivieren.
Das sollte man dem Arzt noch sagen.
Er solle die Tochter anrufen
und informieren.- Gut.
Das wäre es.
Alles andere
wird sowieso neu besprochen.
Die Frau
sollten wir auch kontaktieren.
Noch ein paar Minuten, dann
ist die Nachtschicht endlich vorbei.
Ich verabschiede mich
noch von den anderen.
Macht es gut. Tschau, Elfi.
Tschau. Tschüss.
- Tschau.- Tschau, tschau.
Schlaf gut.
- Tschüss, danke. Bis am Mittwoch.
Merci.
Ah, schön.
Es war eine eher ruhige Nacht
für Rebecca.
Aber man muss
seine Kräfte einteilen können.
Der Beruf verlangt einem viel ab.
Die junge Pflegefachfrau hat
noch zwei Nachtschichten vor sich.
Jetzt hat sie nur noch einen Wunsch:
ins Bett.
In der nächsten Folge
ist Hélène in ihrem letzten Praktikum
und beweist Fürsorglichkeit.
Das erste Mal
leitet Fanny einen Einsatz.
Als wir ihn stupften,
reagierte er nicht.
Sie versucht, das Leben
eines bewusstlosen Mannes zu retten.
Und Rebecca
hat ihre Ausbildung abgeschlossen
und kündet bei der Post.
Ich spüre die Aufregung.
Sie ist eine liebenswerte Person.
Sie wird mir fehlen.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022